c'est déprimant genre surtout quelqu'un
que tu reviens de ton confinement puis
quatre jours après terreau confiner le
sait c'est lourd puis arrive pas à
prendre le dessus chance parce qu'ils
sont constamment chamboulé j'ai comme
l'impression de perdre les belles
journée de ma fille tu es
le chef du basket notre sport études je
suis en chimie physique et en maths
forte
karim benali karoubi a enfin le droit de
sortir pour quelques lancers il termine
sa troisième période de confinement on
est un code positif
c'était le gars qui est en amont cosy
donc on a été confiné on a eu
deux autres cas précédents notre klaus
chaque fois il a dû s'isoler de sa
famille pendant plusieurs jours
la faune est sur un autre cellulaire vu
que j'avais mon sous sol jeudi et mais
je me suis tanné rapidement j'étudie
énormément puis je m'entraîne en amont
sur rose coralie odette elle est
toujours en isolement préventif on a
comme était en confinement un peu puis
un autre confinement pour l'autre
personne
l'excès commun de confinement même tâche
pour commencer l'année scolaire sortait
déjà de l'ordinaire les adolescentes de
3e 4e et 5e secondaires sont en classe
un jour sur deux en zone rouge
on a fait un bond présent dans le futur
un bain prou au bois près de 1200 élèves
fréquentent l'école polyvalente arvida
puis de la moitié d'entre eux sont en
sports arts études dans une vingtaine de
disciplines non seulement les
enseignants enseignants en ligne à tout
le groupe mais dans bien des cas elles
doivent le faire danser et kroon c'est à
dire que non un groupe demain ils vont
enseigner à des élèves à la maison en
même temps pour ceux qui sont en
isolement
tout le monde faire on fait de notre
mieux pour comme dealé avec ce tir avec
ce qui se passe en ce moment mais c'est
sûr c'est vraiment su ciel sur le moral
moi je m'attendais pas sa meilleure
année de ma vie secondaire 5 tb pluvieux
au sport on joue c'est cesse-t-on années
comme si ton année fait le bal
on n'aura rien notre sol a sûrement fait
je trouve sa place incertitude consignes
sanitaires en constante évolution
augmentation des cas alors demande
vraiment beaucoup d'adaptation à ces
jeunes là depuis le début de l'année le
poids de la pandémie
s'ajoute alors qu'ils vivent un moment
charnière dans la construction de leur
identité selon ce psychologue
adolescence d'un moment pour développer
des relations interpersonnelles positive
où on consolide démenti telle estime de
soi on est en relation avec les black
cats ont limé 14 jours en isolement
on les prive de tout ça on est comme
dans le moment qu'on a le goût notre
liberté
puis on a le goût d'apprendre de
nouvelles choses plus on est comme
contraire à rester dans notre chambre
puis attendre que le temps poste lors de
notre passage
environ 30% de la population de l'école
étaient en isolement préventif 10
développe tranquillement c'est la part
de leur apport type de le donner
alors parent alors grands parents leurs
frères à leur sort la crainte de ramener
la corée de la maison fait augmenter
l'anxiété de roscoe rallye je vais peut
être la raison de donner à quelqu'un
d'autre pu mettre sa vie en danger
elle croit qu'il serait temps que son
école donne tous ses cours en ligne mais
son directeur n'en est pas convaincu
pour que ce soit une solution de dernier
recours
parce que ça allait déjà un impact très
fort au niveau 1 la santé psychologique
des gens un jeune qui confine à la
maison pendant un mois un mois et demi
ça le des impacts et deux salles et gros
impact sur la motivation scolaire
karim est rose coralie garde espoir
qu'ils auront un bal de finissants mais
la pandémie
les force à revoir leurs attentes pour
la fin de l'année scolaire se font en
avant une saison de basket au moins de
trois contre trois c'est juste voir une
amie dit est juste ça ferait du ping
seul le temps pourra leur redonner leur
insouciance
[Musique]